a gentleman who I have known for damn
near 20 years got to meet him years ago
we have I'm not gonna lie
felt at each other on occasion around a
poker table and that's not a metaphor
for anything oh and he is the star of
Brock Meyer IFC which has gotten for its
fourth season which drops on Hulu
tomorrow night
100% on the old Rotten Tomatoes 101
hunting it 100 the star of Brock Meyer
IFC my buddy Hank Azaria back here on
the show how are you Henry I'm good how
are you we have felt at each other and
we have felt each other you know what
yeah no I understand that
I understand that I'm going through the
mental rolodex right now to see who can
actually confirm such a thing but well I
met you know the emotional I feel you oh
I see okay which which I probably felt
probably also because we felt you
several times that's true I know our you
know respective dogs may they rest in
peace have been in each other's houses I
mean those are emotion yeah for all of
us to remember so at least accidentally
bumped into each other good to chat with
you Hank and congrats on the Brock Meyer
run Congrats on all of that man I
remember when you first were doing that
around the poker table like legitimately
using that voice around the poker table
and now bringing it from the Funny or
Die video to IFC and now the final
season on Hulu Congrats on all that sir
yeah it was truly workshopped
around the card table by the way we we
got a hundred on Rotten Tomatoes every
year but one we only got one bad review
in in all four years who is that nicest
one it was that person thing who is that
person doing that I remember who it is
because you remember the bad ones Verne
gay from Newsday I don't know what what
was eating him that day but he was the
one person on it like I don't know 40
some-odd not like you hold a grudge or
anything Hank not like you
it's not like he should be worried when
every time he starts his car or anything
well the final season of the hulu on
hulu may be a shameless one through
three right now available on Hulu
Benjamin twenty two minutes per eight
episodes person you can
that's one quarantine afternoon okay you
can just through them all and then
Season four drops I can't say tomorrow
tomorrow fantastic well congrats on all
that do you want to ask the Pope
question at Hank here Christopher
that's good Pope I found a poll question
yeah was been natural oh really
you didn't even stutter the natural why
I love that movie that's one of those
movies not only is it my favorite
baseball movie but it's one of those
movies that goes in my pantheon of if
it's on I will watch it to the end
remote drama a remote drop doesn't
matter where it is it doesn't matter cuz
dunno you know Goodfellas is up there
with me in that front the fugitive is
another one of those movies where it
doesn't matter you got a drop and wrote
the naturals that way for you yes I'm
good yes Godfather wanted to yes if it's
on I must watch it but you know here's
if I asked this on Twitter the other day
because a certain great movies we'll all
watch if they're on yes like those are
all good movies
is there any horrible movie that it
could telling you my I have two really
bad movies that if they're on I will
walk out the floor Hank what do you have
cocktail and then the the granddaddy of
them all is Road outta Road house I was
going to say they were both on over the
weekend no I didn't even know that I
just I actually have a poster of
Roadhouse I'm looking at it right in
front of me is my buddy already gave me
the painting you know if I look to my
left I have the poster of Roadhouse
those are the two things in my office oh
my gosh because we were discussing that
Roadhouse because I had mentioned I have
never seen Hank Roadhouse credits too
I've always dropped in and singing here
there I can't I can try
I actually pick up the remote after a
while I can't get through it I just
can't on the opposite my god I can't
I've seen it dozens of times god I love
it
you know why the fights are fun the
fights are fun the music is fun Jack
really do a lot of good blues music in
it and it's just so bad it's good it's
just so horrible as Ben Gazzara doing
this crazy over-the-top villain and Sam
Elliott you know hitting you mean going
that hurts doesn't it it's just
fantastic
oh my god what do you what don't you
like about cocktail yeah I love
cocktails ah it's just a bad I
considered a bad movie but not a second
of it is believable the two bartenders
take over the world I don't understand
their prank there they're flipping the
drinks around as they as they make a
cocktail they're flair how exactly it's
fun I like I think I enjoy watching the
screenwriter really strange like how
it's a bartender going to matter in the
world the next 10 pages of this script I
don't know what what has what's the most
you had to rehearse something like
similar to flipping something up in the
air for any of the roles that you've
done thank Oh easily
I went to an Mystery Men when I played
the blue Raja I had to actually learn
some sleight of hands good sport by
making Forks appear
what's appear yeah I had to actually
learn some spork sleight of hand you
know what I forgot to go out I forgot
about mystery men so you've been in two
films with the word mystery in the title
that and mystery Alaska they almost came
out concurrently and they were part of a
triple play that nearly ended my career
all did so poorly was complete failure
Herman Herman said Herman said no that
was that was on the way up that was like
a break and that you know gotta be
working what was Helen the three big
rakes I got that all went into the
toilet almost concurrently mystery
Alaska mystery men and Godzilla what
yeah the Matthew Broderick version yeah
oh my gosh
well maybe people are dropping their
remotes because it's too good of a bad
movie mystery Alaska doesn't get a lot I
like that movie
neither his mystery mint they're both
actually all three why not bad at all
mr. man's a very fun movie didn't do
very well at the box office mystery
Alaska is a perfectly fine movie well
and Godzilla's not as bad as people make
it out at all well thankfully it's all
worked out well for you Hank from
everything that you've done also The
Simpsons is in season
3000 correct is that what it is what 32
we actually just we just we just read
our seven hundred episodes insane
nothing gets says nothing that's totally
crazy
well and now I have see Brock Meyer the
fourth season available on Hulu just
were all seasons one through three is it
possible that I could get is it possible
I could get Brock Meyer on the phone is
he is he there Hank is Brock Meyer there
to help us work through a lot of the
issues with the with baseball because in
the in the fourth season that drops on
Hulu on Tuesday
Brock Meyer becomes Commissioner of
baseball in that season correct he does
that that's the future that we Manuel we
take I almost think it might happen we
were so pre cognitively season four from
the pandemic - pandemic - the disputed
lands for the riots - to the heat -
baseball going away almost I mean we
like called it it's really almost a
little freaky and there's a couple other
predictions we make like Joel wrote an
amazing episode a lot of the season is
about how a a really credible almost
like black mirror kind of storyline
where an Alexa type you know operating
system free
much takes over and it's really funny
and really believable I think but yeah
so let me see if I can yeah would you
mind that's a great elmer fudd one said
yes - he's around here someplace
so let me yeah just a Sufis er and bite
you know I also gives me time to pull up
you know the funny things which Jim
prioritising Jim Rodman hey Jim it's
been 10 my dear friend my dear follicly
challenged friends which isin it's it's
good to chat with you again Jim as you
know I've been a big fan of yours for a
long time and it's just really great to
see how everything's worked out for you
in the end well you were there at the
beginning that you did our original
short on on Funny or Die yes and then I
got my big break but nobody else would
touch me yes miss you employed me - you
were talking on your your NFL show I
went on there yes so so thank you I have
I owe it all to you the same way that
you know John Travolta is embedded - to
Quentin Tarantino I'm indebted to you
thank you Michael
I appreciate that Jim I'll take that as
a compliment so what what what do you
think of the current Major League
Baseball negotiations Jim Oh [ __ ] I
gotta hand it to the MLB you have to
because watching these contract
negotiations
it's just highlighted what major league
baseball is very good at tonight because
what says baseball more than a boring
and unproductive back and forth I mean
how is it that they have managed to
remind everybody in America about the
worst aspects of baseball while
simultaneously not playing a single game
absolutely unbelievable who's uh you
know whose fault is it Jim do you think
it's the owners and the players what are
you or do you place the blame here I
just I just want this whole charade in
negotiations to just go away and be done
because I'm quite interested in how a
50-game season
would play out it's such a small amount
amount again yes but I think the team
that will benefit the mode homeowners
would be the New York Mets because
usually usually they get your hopes up
and then collapse but with 50 games no
time to collapse could be just hope the
hopes up so just at 50 games you could
just you could just get it all out of
the ways what you're saying Jim for the
Mets
um for the Mets yeah but that would be
really surreal seeing that I mean I
would like to see it personally
because I mean somebody's gonna win five
games and get the Sion the would you
know want to see that I want to see
Mookie Betts win the Dodgers of World
Series but have no fans to see it in
person I want to see that and I can't
wait to see a picture properly sanitized
a baseball for coronavirus right before
throwing at the head of an Astros dad I
want to be a broadcasting legend Jim
Brock Meyer kind enough to hop on the
phone here in advance of Brock Meyer on
IFC hitting Hulu starting on Tuesday
just like all the three previous seasons
but what but maybe there'll be crowd
noise pumped into a stadium right isn't
that a possibility that is possible I
I'm excited to see that two games
without fans in the stands there are
quite like if you do pipe in that crowd
noise so it sounds like a normal game
I'm afraid of the sound of that Ruby
played in Boston I think a recording of
the fans at Fenway will need the same
kind of disclaimer they're gonna get to
gone with the wind back just like this
recording from a different time people
didn't know about 10 months ago please
forgive us
you're gonna make it authentic Jim Brock
Myer man oh man look man I'm just I'm
thrilled again what's happened for you
and and I I know this may be something
you weren't planning on talking about
but you and Musburger have you buried
the hatchet or is that still despite
everything that's gone down and your and
your your journey is a human that we've
all seen play out over the four seasons
at Brock Myer are you and on Musburger
still on
feuding from all those years Rich Eisen
it's very difficult to bury the hatchet
with a man who thought it was funny to
poop in your hotel I saw that on an
episode that hee hee that was true in
fact in season 4 we kind of
flash-forward 12 years into the future
and as you say Brock Myers Commissioner
baseball he's finally gets inducted into
the Hall of Fame and he's having a
little bit of difficulty finding someone
to give his intro speech scrambling
around looking at the guest list
to see who's there that day and he goes
down this is like oh no can't ask a must
regret he pooped in my bed so he dies
and so did Levantine sort of dan patrick
boy this list is irregular who's who
look kiddo Putin says Jim brought mine
so I guess over the next 12 years you
will go on to season Jim Bravo cars
getting hits by the way that's something
to look forward to I can I can look
forward to that Jim I can really do I
think the idea was shown is that after
and I hope this you know it's not for a
long time but after brent musburger
passes it becomes a way to honor his
memories in my bed well Jim Congrats on
the show really appreciate you hopping
on would you put Hank back on the phone
for a quick second so I could say a
proper goodbye to him Jim yeah I mean if
you want to talk to him he's a little
boring but you know it really was great
I hope you didn't mind me asking just
specifically to have Jim on the phone
like that no no listen I'm quite used to
you know listen I used to be married to
Helen Hunt I'm used to you know somebody
else taking the lead being the star of
the family I'm used to well I don't know
if you wear this Hank but we went down
this day in history to see what to talk
about him that's what led to our poll
question it was 32 years ago today that
Bull Durham was in theaters for the
first time whose birthday is it today
hey hey Hank its Helen Hunt's Bert
today are you I must have it must that
must be dirt buried deep in the recesses
of my sub 20 years oddly enough it's the
same thing with my ESPYs invite question
well the nancial was my favorite
baseball movie yes sir what is your
favorite sports movie I have a
definitive favorite sports a lot over
the last few weeks it's Hoosiers Hank
the Tudors right and well here's the
issue as we had the director of Hoosiers
and Rudy on David on spa because he
heard me slag on Rudy calling it pure
fiction
and that never has the word based in
based on a true story done more heavy
lifting he came on and said no that's
compared to other sports movies it's
like a Ken Burns documentary and then
proceeded to tell Hank how Hoosiers
other than the fact that the the the
school hickory had won a championship
that the writer Angela Pizza visited the
town and said it's such a boring story
nothing happened we can't do the movie
the whole thing's made up everything
about it is made up is what he said I
don't care they made it up well and how
about this one how about this one this
is the thing that really gutted me I
asked him if he had a twist Hackman's
arm to make the movie hang
he said that Hackman was what he did he
use the word difficult because it was
his first movie davidann spa yeah
Hackman Hackman was so not into the film
that you remember the montage when
hickory starts winning and you see
you see you see you know what the the
music and everything's going well and
you see the character played by Dennis
Hopper laughing and slapping his knee
remember that he said that he learned
two years before Hopper Todd hopper told
him what hoppers laughing at is Hackman
saying to him off-camera I hope you've
invested well because once this movie
comes out we're never gonna have a
career anymore there's so many stories
like that you know that Burt Reynolds
what was going to fire his agents after
he saw a cut of Boogie Nights know these
green of remedies like I'm firing
everyone who works for me I did anyway
he's watching the finished product now
he's like III will this is an
abomination how do these people let me
do this look at how he was nominated for
I know in the ease of fact he left the
set of mystery Alaska to go to that
Academy Awards right huh which is a
whole nother story of that story boy you
know I know because now I'll be
dishonouring a man's memory huh
let's just say he was very very very
very cranky that night
mm wasn't shy about it man Hank you are
the you're the best best to Kate and in
your old family and we'll chat soon okay
Kerry great to talk to you that's
Henry's area that's Hank is here the
greatest at Hank Azaria on both Twitter
and Instagram check out again on Hulu as
rock Meyer would say seasons 1 through
now soon to be four hey you watched all
the way to the end thanks for that watch
more right here